-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy- and Golden Globe-winning
actor who currently stars as
Logan Roy in "Succession."
The Season 3 finale
airs this Sunday at 9:00 p.m.
on HBO and is available
to stream on HBO Max.
Please welcome to the show
Brian Cox!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you.
-Welcome to the show, Brian.
-I've been a fan of yours
for a long time
and love you in "Succession."
I've been lucky enough to have
some of your castmates
on the show.
And I ask them --
I ask them on camera,
"What is Brian like
in real life?"
And they've said you're a
sweetheart and a Teddy bear,
but in both cases, like,
maybe they didn't quite mean it.
-It's in their interests
not to mean it.
-Yeah.
It's such a fantastic --
For anyone who is behind enough
not to be watching "Succession,"
you play the patriarch of
this, you know, media family
and, sort of at their core,
really awful people.
But I read that you say
it was very important to you,
when you took the part,
that the character Logan Roy,
you asked
the creator of the show,
"Does he love his children?"
-Yeah.
-Why was that an important
question for you to ask him?
-Because he seems to be
a man who is loveless,
and it's very important that
people know that --
Well, actually,
it's not important
that the audience knows at all,
but it's very important
that I knew that I did,
indeed, love my children.
And, of course,
once you have that in mind
and that as part of you,
that enables you to do
all kinds of things
within the role.
And sometimes, you obfuscate,
you don't tell the truth
about your situation,
and he does that a lot.
He keeps people at a distance,
almost deliberately, you know?
And it's also, he's got his own
crap, as well, you know.
-It works, the show.
I think one of the reasons
people are drawn to it,
it works incredibly well
as a drama.
It's also deeply funny.
-Very funny.
-You have some
incredible lines on the show.
Are they as much fun to say as
they are to hear when watching?
-Yeah, I mean, they are.
Especially when they give them
to you at the last minute.
-Okay. So they're not in
the script, per se.
-They're not in the script.
And then, suddenly, he'll say,
"Why don't you say that
your 'unh' tastes like
cream cheese
when it 'unh-unhs'?"
And I go, "Oh, okay, fine."
So, I walk on and I do,
"Your 'unh' is the 'unh'
when it 'unh-unhs.'"
And then I've said it and it's
done and it's out there.
-If you have a catchphrase,
I'm gonna show you
that we don't have to do what
you've been doing.
If you have a catchphrase,
it's "[Bleep] off."
-"[Bleep] off."
-Yeah.
And you actually wore the --
It was very appropriately
on a mask when you --
Is that something that now --
Is the character popular enough
that fans want you to say
it to them?
-Oh, all the time.
I mean, it's one of the
great things to say to somebody,
'cause, you know,
they'll come up to you and say,
"Uh, could you say
'[Bleep] off'?"
And you go, "[Bleep] off."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's really nice.
-You know, and, so,
my best story about that --
and this is absolutely true --
so, I'm in L.A.,
and it was at the time of
the Golden Globes.
And Rosanna Arquette,
who's a lovely lady,
invited me --
We did a movie together.
She invites me to this afternoon
with Ronan Farrow.
And he's reading from his book,
and it's very intense
and very incredible,
what he's writing about.
And all these Hollywood women
are completely attentive to him,
you know, as he's going through
chapter and verse of his book.
And, you know,
it's amazing work.
And, so, I arrive late,
so I'm standing at the back.
And I'm looking at this and
thinking, "Wow, this is intense.
This is really intense,
all this stuff."
And then he finishes,
and they give him
a round of applause.
And then they turn
'round and they see me
and they all come at me
and they take their device out
and they say, "Can you tell me
to [bleep] off?"
And you go,
"This is a MeToo meeting.
And I am a white dinosaur.
And you're asking this
white dinosaur
at this MeToo meeting
to tell you to [bleep] off?
Something doesn't seem right."
-Right. Sounds like a trap.
-Oh, it does.
But, also, you know --
And that's human nature.
-Yeah.
People like what they like.
It doesn't matter the context.
-Human beings are so confused.
-When I watch Logan Roy,
you know,
when I saw you in the part,
I thought, the first time I ever
saw you on film was "Manhunter,"
which people -- is a great film.
-You're not old enough, surely.
-No, I worked in a video store,
so I got to --
-Oh, I see.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got to watch --
I got to rent videos.
And "Manhunter,"
for people that don't know,
you played Hannibal Lecktor for
the first time on film,
in this fantastic
Michael Mann movie.
And I would imagine --
Is it dissimilar?
'Cause you've obviously played
a lot of villains
throughout your career --
some fictional, some real-life.
Do you always approach it the
same way as Logan Roy?
Do you have to find some part of
them to be empathetic towards?
-Well, you have to find --
The rule number one is, when you
play a role, you don't judge.
You must never judge,
because that guides you
into all kinds of territory
which is meaningless.
So you don't judge
who you're playing.
You play it from
his point of view,
and however confused
that point of view may be.
And you have to find
a way into that,
and that's, to me, part of
the craft of being an actor.
You have to actually make
it real, make it true.
I mean, if you're playing
Hermann Goering, for example,
you know, who is regarded
as probably one of
the most vile people of
the 20th century,
you know that his background
was very complicated,
because he was a major flier
in the German air force.
He abandoned his planes
in Switzerland
because he was disgusted by
the Treaty of Versailles.
He then went
and had a nervous breakdown
and lived in Sweden
for some time.
Then he came back and he noticed
this young painter from Vienna
was stirring everything up,
and he put his whole thing
towards, you know,
the future of Adolf Hitler.
So you realize
that there's a man
who came from a certain
point of view
and arrived at a pretty hideous
point of view, you know.
And I think that's life.
That's what happens.
-I'm reading your book,
which is fantastic.
We were talking
about it backstage.
And you said something about
being an actor
which stuck with me.
You said,
"Every day is a school day."
Is that something that --
Obviously, you've been doing
this for a long time.
You know, started onstage,
been doing film and television
now for a great many years.
Do you feel like you're learning
something new every day?
-All the time.
You never stop learning.
-And are you learning it
from your own trial and error
or from the people
you work with?
-I mean, it's basically from
one's own trial and error,
but you also learn from the
struggles of others, as well,
that you see around you.
And you see,
"Why is there a problem there?",
and then you examine their
relationship to that problem
and how they solved
that problem, and that's great.
I mean, that's a wonderful thing
to be part of.
You know, 'cause they're all --
You know, in my book,
I was accused of disrespecting
certain actors recently.
And I don't disrespect anybody
that's involved
in this profession,
because it's too hard
a profession to disrespect.
I do have reservations about
certain talent,
and I'll just say, "Well, I'm
not sure that guy or that gal
is quite this or that,"
you know, but that's
the way it is.
But I certainly
would not disrespect,
because it's a tough job.
But it's a joyous job
at the same time.
-I would imagine, too, you
end up performing with people
who have very
different approaches.
There was just a
fascinating profile about
the wonderful actor
Jeremy Strong,
who's in your show,
and it strikes me
that his approach to it
is very different
from maybe the fellow castmates.
Is that --
-It certainly is.
I mean, it certainly is.
I mean, the thing about
Jeremy's approach is,
it works in terms of
what comes out the other end.
My problem with --
And it's not a problem.
I don't have a problem with
Jeremy, 'cause he's delightful.
I mean, he's one of the best
fathers I've ever come across.
He has these three little girls,
and he's an extraordinary dad.
I mean, he really is.
He's a pretty unique individual.
But he does get obsessed
with the work,
and I worry about
what it does to him.
Because if you can't
separate yourself --
You know,
'cause you're dealing with
all this material every day.
You can't live in it.
You know, eventually,
you get worn out.
Like, to me, Dan Day-Lewis
got worn out at 55.
He decided to retire
'cause he couldn't go on
doing that every day.
You know, it was too consuming.
And I do worry about it.
I mean, but the result --
Whatever one says about Jeremy,
the result
is always extraordinary
and excellent.
-Can I --
Yeah, please, for Jeremy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can I take a moment?
I have a very good
Kendall Roy impression
I'd like to do for you.
-Yeah.
-Alright.
"Uh...Dad..."
[ Laughter ]
Pretty good, right?
-It's that face.
-Yeah.
-He has that face.
-I have a face --
I have a good starting-point
face for Kendall.
-Yeah, you have a very good
Kendall Roy face.
-The thing I had to -- Like, my
whole day was working on that.
-Well, you did it very well.
-Thank you.
-And it was so incredibly brief.
-Thank you. Well, that's...
You know, I don't know what
you heard from
your acting teachers,
but mine always said --
After they watched me,
they said, "Maybe shorter?"
-So you clearly
learned the lesson.
-Just keep it shorter.
They were like, "Try brief."
I mean, you talk -- You know,
you've always played
a lot of Shakespeare onstage,
and that strikes me
as very a grueling
part of your early career --
And even later career, like,
doing stage work like that.
Does it -- Like, when you
find yourself doing television,
does it feel like a relief
compared to those days?
-No, I mean, television has a
different set of problems.
I mean, you have to sustain,
for one thing,
and you have these times --
I mean, I'm very lucky,
because I'm blessed
with probably the best crew
that I've ever worked with,
and they're fast,
and you never notice
the hanging about,
whereas, a lot of films,
you're waiting for the lighting
to get done and everything,
so you have to develop
a great deal of
patience in the working of it.
But, I mean, theater's just --
It's a different animal.
And, as a different animal,
it has a different set of
fears and gratitudes
at the same time.
-Well, it's wonderful to
see you in any medium,
and I really appreciate you
making time for us today.
-Not at all.
It's lovely to be here.
-Thank you so much.
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Brian Cox, everybody.
The Season 3 finale
of "Succession"
airs Sunday at 9:00 p.m.
on HBO and is available to
stream on HBO Max.
And do check out his book,
as well.